and dennis smith jr gets a robinson
screen
or topping screen rather and goes back
to ob topping with it
to the basket lays it up lays it in nice
we'll be topping with the basketball
he did it all in dayton and did it all
right there
by himself folks i like him george up
and tapped that rebound away from
everybody else still has it drives it
dishes to kevin knox knox inside and he
gets a jam for ob
topping they're gonna love him in new
york i think so uh he's uh igniting that
bench right now
here they come topping has it but he's
not gonna try a tough shot there blake
griffin came over to cut him off so he
gave it up and smartly
stayed alive and available and there's
the
skywalking ability george right
[Music]
everybody seems to really love what's in
front of killian hayes
dennis smith jr all with an eye towards
limiting travel and
just curtailing any possibilities as
much as you can
of the virus spreading george knox got a
split
[Applause]
here's topping moving so well with that
basketball in his hands
constantly with the hoop but he draws a
foul he's constantly on the attack
you know never